[music]
Hi I'm Banny Banerjee. I'm Professor
of the Practice in School of Earth Energy and
Environmental Sciences here at Stanford and also director of Stanford ChangeLabs
uh, a group that looks at innovation
methodologies for very large-scale transmissions.
My background is in in the
field of architecture and architectures
taught me how to look at
systems in very layered ways where you look
at, ah, systems that have engineering aspects to it
and systems that, ah,  that have human or
cultural aspects to it and how do you
look at, ah, creating something new.
And I
worked right before Stanford
I worked for just under a decade at a company called IDEO
which is a design company and, ah
a design and innovation company and then I came to
Stanford
and I worked, uh,  as the director of the design program  at here.
My background
is is design and innovation and
increasingly over the years I've been
looking at innovation methodologies for
transforming systems at scale. Energy
something that is written into the way
we operate and any one little thing that
we do might have an energy footprint but
we don't think about it so it is, uh,  death
by a thousand cuts.
Ah, my work is directed towards, ah  creating methodologies,
approaches, tools and and and mindsets
around how do you change, ah, systems when the
problems
large, complex, urgent and very very
difficult to understand where to approach from.
[music]